non l'année 90 sera un grand cru pour le
tourisme dans la capitale et parmi les
touristes étrangers les japonais et
leurs appareils photos ils seront plus
d'un million cette année à visiter paris
plus d'un million à dépenser sans
compter
dans les boutiques de luxe eric yao
savez vous combien dépensent un touriste
japonais aisée quand il est à paris huit
mille francs par jour et par personne un
touriste japonais modeste ne dépensant
si on peut dire que 2000 francs par jour
et par personne
car les nippons qui restent en moyenne
trois jours à paris veulent tous voir
les monuments les musées les cabarets
ils veulent aussi tout achetés dans des
magasins de détaxe spécialisés qui
travaillent avec les tour opérators sont
les gens qui recherchent des marques
françaises prestigieuse qui sont très
chers au japon et qu'elle trouve ici un
prix plus abordable abordable mais qui
reste tout de même qu'au quai 1200
francs le foulard 450 francs la cravate
2000 francs et plus le sac à main sans
parler des parfums des produits de
beauté des bijoux de la vaisselle fine
qui font le bonheur des nippons mais
aussi du trésor français car les
touristes japonais ont rapporté l'an
dernier à la france un revenu de plus de
8 milliards de francs revenus qui
devraient être encore plus important
dans les années qui viennent par le
nombre des vacanciers japonais devrait
doubler d'ici à 1995